our Allstars can do a lot more than just skate
and score they too shall pass as it's time for
the NHL passing challenge players will have
45 seconds to skate up and down the ice while
taking aim at clusters of targets set up
along the boards the smaller the target
the more points it's worth with chances
to earn one two or three points with each
pass after firing five passes as they travel
from crease to crease six more puns will be
waiting three in each end the player whose
passes earn the most points takes our top
spot so this is the most popular event of the
evening the passing challenge returns after a
fouryear absence there's David Pasto he's not in
this competition talking to William nander who
is in this competition and as you can see Nathan
McKinnon now with five points at plus 750 on our
ESPN bet odds couple guys from Nova SCA they'll be
teammates mess in the All-Star game tomorrow yep
not a bad Duo right there Crosby was McKinnon's
first draft pick last night in the players draft
he grew up watching Sydney Crosby and emulated
a lot of his office work ethic and brought that
to the rink each and every day and one of the
hardest working players in the game as we know
and the results are because of it his results
are because of it he so righties will go first
in the NHL All-Star passing challenge attempting
11 passes all on the forehand a possible 33 points
so Nathan McKinnon Banks five after we eliminate
two all these points still matter all the way
through the end of the night so every competition
every rep matters we don't erase and start over
at any point and McKinnon's probably he's still
a little confused that probably happened right
in the skills competition do I have this right
you want to make sure you have it right there's
a lot at stake here you don't want to be out there
going through the wrong drill or the wrong target
so they're really explaining to him now make
sure he's fully aware of what he's supposed to
be doing and this is a uh this is a highly skilled
uh event right here for every one of these players
naan mckinon have a monster year passing the
puck this year he's got 53 assists and here he
goes
passing on the move another two-pointer there
[Applause] two nothing on that [Applause]
one he's got to get he wasn't sure what to
do there now he's to pass all the way across
the ice misses again so here we go [Music]
got to hurry up now clock is winding down he's
not going to get I think oh he got to go rapid
fire here going to get the buzzer boom I don't
think that last one's going to count he didn't
have an on a stick controversy so for now 13
points for Nathan McKinnon again a possible 33
what he was at a little bit of a disadvantage
going first here because he didn't look like
he knew exactly what was supposed to be going
on looked a little unsure of the uh little the
sequence so again William neander also what do
I go first I'm sure the NHL sent these guys an
email with what to do and a video example my
guess they didn't open it you got put on the
bottom of the barel so William neander goes
he was in the fastest skater competition he
accumulated one point for that Austin Matthews
is the only guy hasn't got a point yet of course
it's early one it's a two-point from nander
he's flying another two so he you can see he
realized after the buzzer went off I got to pick
up the pace a little bit here get to my next Puck
there we go solid contact he looks a little more
sure what he's up to now now he's to go all the
way over with these this probably will be the
difference the guy who you know gets three in
a row here yep on the long one now he's going
to get on his horse to beat the clock and he
will he's got lots of time he can take his time
time obviously the smaller the target the more
points so neander finishing with
16 points that edges McKinnon
by three he's the current leader
as you can see nine more guys to
go so you're right mckinon was kind of the
guinea pig wasn't he going first I don't
think no one knew really what to do I think
the players have a much better understanding
of the pace they need to do it with now
to get their all the shots there all the
pass passes in and I think they know exactly
the route that they have to take so k a big
Advantage a car up next I think these players are
better when they do it at game speed they're used
to doing at a game speed instead of kind of taken
a little bit of a l Fair attempt at it the quicker
they play that's what their more natural instinct
is car lost control there gets it back he went for
the big Target there missed it there we got that
one got that one got that one he's won a rookie
of the year a Norris a Smite a Stanley Cup a
Hobie baker man what a start gaale Mark Carr
is going he's going for the big one oh tremendous
hockey player 14 points H needs to beat neander
16 nice one nice one we got a new leader oh three
that's big well done all the way up to 23 points
neander with the hockey clap kale Mar is our new
leader that was impressive down the stretch did
he get points for that that looked like it just
grazed The Edge I know I was like I'm looking like
Matthew barzel is up next this guy loves the pass
certainly he'll be one of the favorites in this
competition I like Leon Dr settle in this
competition as well mhm one of the best passers
of National Hockey League so here comes barzel
oh miss that swinging a Miss on pass number one
slower Pace here go he went for the big one and
nailed it and I think he went outside does he have
to stay inside the uh [Music] goes so now three
long passes only at nine points got to get some
big numbers here misses that one I don't want to
be a stickler on the rules Gucci but is he going
outside the Middle Lane there that he's supposed
to stay in was a little he made the pass a little
shorter that little orange strip down the middle
of the ice I think he was venturing out of that he
needs big numbers here he misses it yes last one
got it so not bad 21 points in second place two
behind ma barzal got four in the fastest skater oh
wait you're getting a little close to the Target
though trying to get a GPS for this competition M
we need to Old School directions now they brought
the paper take a ride to the second light find
the Denny's make the legal U-turn exactly I
don't know I don't think they did enough
preparation before this one this seems to
be a little confusing for the players but they've
had enough opportunity now to watch what needs to
be done I think we can put the paper away now
B I think so so J JT Miller disappointing one
timer competition a half a point he's our first
Lefty to go starting at the other end obviously
we mentioned righties go first the rest will be
left-handed they'll start the other end cuz they
don't want to move the targets just keep in
the same spot nice solid two-point start for
Miller misses that [Applause] one misses that one
picks up the puck of the blue line good one there
I I have to say you got to take into account
the nerves for these guys that are you know
not used to being in these skills competition
at this level and seems to be a little nervous
to me yeah he's uh going for the small Target
missed all three only at Five Points here with
there's a little pressure down there you know you
don't you wouldn't think about it but I remember
doing that backy shooting there going out and
I can feel my legs a little bit little little
tremble little absolutely [Music] absolutely
so JT Miller you voted in by the fans seven
points JT was just a little nervous uh you could
tell little hesitant up next Nikita kucherov we
talked about his monster season even better than
his MVP season an absolute future Hall of Famer
what a career he's building John Cooper Raves
about his commitment so last year his season
ends and they lose to the maple Lea took about a
week off rented a rank in Tampa and was on the ice
every day yeah practicing and it's showing this
year he's really kind of got a good opportunity
to rest because it didn't go deep into the
playoff but for me one of the for me one of
the I'm not sensing a lot of intensity here m
not quite not quite enough intensity whatsoever
here but I love the way he plays the
game he might he might have got into Tom Wilson's
cooler four points for COV this uh this is not a
good look quite frankly and the fans are booing
them and that's what happens when you don't try
your best and you're in a hockey City like
Toronto they're going to let you know yeah
that Fan's not too pleased with [Applause] the
not a great look for Peter coer off there he's
uh just a five-point effort not sure what was
going through that mind wasn't really into it
from the start well that's his first event that
kind of takes him out of the running for the
million dollars I would have to think yeah he
can't afford a zilch right and uh no now Quinn
Hughes you can't go through an event and not
get any points in order to expect to win this
it's amazed how this young fella mes continues
to just improve on his game he's a legit NHL
Superstar legit nor trophy candidate captain
of the Vancouver conu well got thrust into a
leadership role as Captain of Vancouver connuck
and has not bad at I as play has not diminished
because of it the weight of the captaincy has
not hurt him he's played unbelievable in fact
he's probably playing some of the best hockey of
his career and sometimes you know the pressure of
being a captain trying to do too much there can
weigh on a player but it hasn't affected him one
bit nobody loves hockey like the Hughes Brothers
man Mom and Dad are here for the week the Hugh
Brothers but you're right you get one son go to
the NHL two three and they're all superstars and
they're all superstars they're all amazing
skaters there would it be unbelievable all
three of them on the team Canada unreal right
Team USA team team yeah watch your mouth is
it Team USA would that be amazing or what
they'll all be there I mean they're they're
that good and quinnon going to try to finish up
strong with a two can't quite get it so he's at
15 caror McDavid on deck US wouldn't
borrow wouldn't borrow the Hughes
Brothers to Canada for this trade
we'll trade you two Hughes Brothers for
McDavid so Conor McDavid who won the fastest
skater competition with five points did not
take part in the onetime I expect uh I expect him
to do very well in this competition right here 23
points is the number to beat kale Mar there are
live standings he'll start off with a solid two
want to get some early see he goes for two here
oh he went for little one and he got it up to
Five Points see where he goes here goes little
again didn't get it D got that one he did miss
that he's going big see if he goes big across the
ice no no he missed the middle one now he gets the
middle one so here comes McDavid he'll arrive in
time to get all three of these off he's only got
10 better hit the big numbers misses it missed the
two oh D only 10 I did not see that coming guci oh
good news for Nathan McKinnon he didn't want to
get McDavid out too far in front of him started
out so good start off so good you hear what him
say but it did not end well Emily Kaplan with
Brady Chuck the allstar yeah and Brady you got
two friends here we got Kesler whose Grandpa was
your dad's equipment manager and Maverick whose
dad is Rick uh taket the coaches the kuu so tell
me about these kids why you enjoying it with them
yeah well we know you know got a history and kler
and and you know the Wilson family you know Shelly
Stan's wife was my babysitter growing up and and
of course M with uh you know talk talk and uh you
know of course my dad playing together so it's a
lot of great memories and and kind of go back to
Memory Lane you keep watching Big Walter cross mon
how do you think he's enjoying this oh he's loving
it he's having a great time and uh know we had a
great time last night be able to you know Trail
this together and of course tonight and tomorrow
awesome thanks Brady tell us yeah we talk about
the Hughes as one of those great American Hockey
families put like a Chuck right there Keith should
be in the hall of fame most career goals by a guy
who isn't in the Hall of Fame Matthew and Brady
full-fledged Superstars themselves Elias peton
now nine points see what he does across the ice
he goes with a big boy now he'll go middle to get
some points he'll go so he Ops to go two of the
middle ones M make sure I keep accumula up to 16
yeah you just got to get points you can't get a
puck here especially at this point of the compe
or the event there not get any points oh that was
a good shot there better very good stumble fumble
oh nice we have a new leader you got to finish
strong in this competition finish strong those
last six shots are [Applause] key that was was
impressive from Pon what a year he's having in
Vancouver he's going to be paid handsomely for it
went for the little guy yeah and I tell you what
there something on the ice there you took a little
stumble there ice slipper little sniper ice and
slippery in the 25-year-old swed 27 goals this
year after 39 last year that little stumble is
going to hurt McDavid in the overall now I think
could we'll see so Austin Matthews failed to get
a point in the one-time competition now he'll try
the passing challenge to accumulate some points
he's got some room his teammate William nander at
16 and the big boys three of them over 20 barzel
marar and Pon Here Comes Matthews here where he
starts he goes for the big boy and gets it that's
a three-pointer big Target one the medium two
the little three and he's two for two with the
three-pointer he when I watch him play it looks
like he was born with a puck on his stick it is
he looks so comfortable out there and his it's sh
oh four for four with the little Target already up
to 12 missed that one miss that one another the
long pass to cross he trying to get some have to
hurry a little bit here oh that hurt him there
get the two I thought he might go two twos there
he's got to hurry a little up the 14 should get
all three off see if he can pass at least pass
his teammate there's a two he's up to 60 bam
so he jumps all the way up to 19 he's able to
pass Hughes and McKinnon and nander so he's
going to get these guaranteed points with
only one passer remaining Pon Ma barzel Matthews
the current top four as you see right there five
points for first four for second three for third
two for fourth and one for fifth I think Leon Dr
for me is one of the best passers in the National
Hockey League it's hard to say if has a great goal
score he is but Absolut his passing is backhand
forehand elevated anywhere you can put the puck
anywhere he wants see how he does here we're going
to review Elias Patterson's last shot we're not
sure so we to hold off the standings nothing
on that first one from trial misses the three
there hits that
three-pointer nothing there got that one
now he's got to get hot he's got to get
hot bam three-pointer oh boy not going to do
it now certainly looking good for Pon or Mar
like I said they're reviewing pon bam there's
a three just missed that one just missed that
one so disappointing 12 for Leon dry side off
yeah he W he would definitely disappointed with
that you can see it look in his face there he he
was looking for better results oh yeah well just
think McDavid and dry will combin for 22 who
would have who would have ever that would have
been third place if you combine the two of them
yeah so we want to make sure this is official